Welcome back to the complete guide to Spin.
Spin is a framework for building micro services
and WebAssembly.
Today, I'm gonna guide you through the Rust
SDK.
Let's get started.
Alright.
So, for this Rust SDK,
I'm gonna guide you through each of the
points listed in this markdown file.
One, we're gonna write our first endpoint or
at least modify what Spin has generated for
us.
Next, we'll take a look at extracting information
from the HTTP headers,
then the body,
then some query params,
then a small gotcha with working with Spin
getting the HTTP domain that your application was
served on. And lastly, making an outbound HTTP
request.
So let's start with our endpoint.
When you generate in your HTTP rust microservice,
you get a lib dot r s.
The scaffolding has already generated everything that you
need for your first endpoint
and all it takes is using the macro
HTTP
underscore component.
Now it doesn't matter what you call this
function, but it probably makes sense for this
function to represent the endpoint that you're serving.
Now, how is this endpoint routed? Well, we
use the spin dot toml.
If we take a look at the HTTP
trigger, you can see that we're serving over
slash
And we're actually matching on all
sub paths.
That just means that our endpoint and this
application
will actually be all paths.
Now because spend services are so easy to
write, it probably makes sense to generate a
new spin micro service for every endpoint.
And then you're just modifying the trigger with
a path that you want to capture.
However, if you prefer to go to more
monolithic approach,
there's nothing stopping you from bringing in any
Rust based router or even just a match
statement into your function here and handling the
routing yourself.
However, I feel that best practice leans towards
one microservice for each endpoint and as such
we're going to do that.
So to show that for today, we'll change
our base to be slash hello
world and
our component trigger to only match on this
path.
Now, we can run
spin build
And then we can run spin up follow
all. Follow all is gonna get us the
logs from our component.
So now we can run curl
localhost
3,000
hello
world.
And we get hello fermion from our endpoint.
If we run this again
on the root path,
we actually find
as we get a photo for.
And this is what we want. We only
want our service to be responsible for the
one path at our application.
Check.
So how do we grab request headers? The
spin project provides
request and response objects that you can work
with within spin services.
As such, you can actually see that we
have a print statement to print all of
the headers from our application to the terminal.
So already we're accessing
the headers here.
So let's just confirm
the behavior that we expect.
We can run curl dash h,
x name Rawkode. We're providing our own custom
header here,
where we have local host
3,000
on hello world.
And as you can see here, our header
has been propagated and printed by our HTTP
endpoint.
Now, if you only want to access one
specific header,
like the Rawkode name header.
And we can do a request
headers
get.
Where we can ask
for x name
and now we can change our print statement
to only print the Rawkode name.
Let's run spin build
and spin up follow
all.
And now you see,
we have an option string for the value
of our header of Rawkode.
If we get a typo or we forget
this about header, we'll get a none value.
Just like you would expect with any piece
of Rust code.
Headers,
check.
So now let's take a look at getting
the request body.
Now there is a little bit of type
juggling that has to be done to successfully
get the body as a Rust string.
Let's take a look. Let's start with let
body equals
request
dot body.
Rust analyzer kicks in and tells us that
we have a reference to option
bytes.
Okay. So let's be good to our citizens
and instead of just unwrapping,
we're going to do a match
and could copilot
like so.
Now, when we have
bytes from the body, we just return them
to our variable.
If we get a none, we're going to
return a status of 400
to our client.
Next,
if you need this as a string,
let's say body string equals
string
from UTF eight body to vector.
Now, why do we have to do this
little dance?
Well,
WebAssembly and Rust and Spin are all fairly
performance systems.
As such they use Rust,
Bytes,
which is a zero copy slice implementation
that makes a very fast networking code.
But for you to work with them and
your endpoint, you probably wanna coerce them into
a string.
Now the string trait does provide a from
UTFE,
which we can use on a vector of
bytes.
And baits baits does provide a two vec
function that we can call on the baits.
This does return our result, so we can
use question mark to throw the error to
the client
or just get back a string.
If you wanna handle this differently, you can
of course match and do whatever you need.
But we are gonna be happy with just
a string.
From here, we can now do another print
line and say the body is
body string.
Like so.
So let's pop back to our terminal,
run spin build
and follow-up.
Now we can run our curl command like
so.
And we see that our body is empty.
So just to make sure everything works as
expected,
let's provide an empty JSON string like so.
So there is a little bit of a
type dance required to get the body as
a string with the Rust SDK,
but once you know how to do it,
it's there whenever you need it.
Next, let's take a look at getting the
query parameters.
So let's pop back to our code
and we'll just remove all the stuff from
our body.
And now we're going to do print ln
query string,
like so. But if we pop open request,
as much as Copilot would love there to
be a query string function, unfortunately,
there is not.
Instead, you have to pull out the URI
where we can request the query.
And right now, I'm just going to do
an unwrap or default, so that we can
do to print on the command line. The
default for that should just be an empty
string.
So we'll run spin build and follow,
and we're just gonna do a simple curl
to hello world.
As you can see, our query string is
non existent.
So, let's modify that and to do so,
we'll need to wrap our curl in quotes.
And I can say that my name is
Rawkode and my age is 21.
And
now our query string is printed out in
the logs above.
Now, you don't need to parse this query
string yourself.
Because we're using Rust, we have access to
whole world of Rust create.
So let's add
the query string create,
like so.
Now we call query string,
queryfy,
passing in our query string.
Now this is going to return
a vector of tuples
with the key and values from the query.
Now we can iterate over the key value
pairs like so. You can grab an iterator
for each
and print, print, print. Thank you Copilot.
Now we can run spin build,
like so.
And bring back our query command, bring back
our curl command.
And we can see our name and age.
Awesome.
Next and last, making an outbound HTTP request.
So it's likely at some point your spend
microservice will want to talk to other parts
of the internet or other spend microservices.
And to do so is really simple.
We can grab the spend,
the spend SDK,
HTTP
and
send.
This gives us the ability to send an
HTTP request to whatever we want.
We can use the HTTP
request
builder
to build up our HTTP query.
So first we'll do method of get
to google.com
with no body,
like so.
Now this does return
a result object,
so we need to add a couple of
question marks.
We can grab the response from the outbound
request like so.
Next, we could use it much like a
proxy, I just dump that straight to the
calling client.
Now this is complaining and it's because the
errors are different. We can fix that with
map error.
Now,
we can run,
spin build
and spin up
follow
all.
We can jump back to our favorite kernel
command, like so.
Now we are presented with an error message
right off the bat.
Spin
tries to be as secure as possible.
And as such, you have to specifically allow
outbound request to certain destinations and domains.
So let's modify our spin.toml
to allow a request to google.com.
So here is our spin.toml.
On the component and on each component,
you can choose to allow outbound traffic.
As such, we could just do an unsecure
allow all
and this will at least get us running,
so that we can run a request.
Like so.
Now we have
a WebAssembly
HTTP proxy
to any website that we want. Well, kind
of.
So let's secure this just a little bit
more.
Instead of doing and secure all,
let's just allow google.com.
Now this shouldn't change our application
and we still get all the outputs from
the Google request.
So let's make one more change
to LibRS
and this time we'll call github.com.
We do a build,
we do a curl
and destination not allowed.
Perfect.
So make an outbound HTTP request
using the Spin SDK for Rust.
It's just a few lines of code. Remember
to update your Spin.TOML,
Be very specific about the outbound request that
you expect to improve your security posture.
And that's it.
That is your introduction to the Rust SDK
for Spin.
Happy hacking. If you ever need any help,
drop into the comments, reach me on Twitter,
or join the Fermion Discord. I'll see you
there.
Have fun.